This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to.
This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to.|||这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之百真人。嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）带来的《以难民的方式学习》（Learn the Hardway）。这个空间旨在探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全但却必须坦诚的对话，而你正在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套或盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是一个好惹的人。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你必须这么做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.|||请在 AHA 广播应用程序、Apple Podcast 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《以难民的方式学习》。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立抗逆力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你将会以一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人的身份从另一端走出来。请收听《2%》。
That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.|||这就是可以在 IHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听的《2%》。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J.
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J.|||他会得到应有的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的女性朋友。听女性朋友的话。相信我，宝贝，请在 Iheart radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回望过去》（Look Back at it）播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和说是个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.|||我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。请在 IHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回望过去》。
Hello and welcome back to the Psychology of Your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back. Welcome back to another episode of the psychology of your 20s, new listeners, old listeners. it's so great to have you here. So great to have you here for this super exciting topic that I am so pumped to talk about today. And that is the psychology of New Year's resolutions. There was no better time to talk about this than now. 2023 is right around the corner. Maybe you're listening to this in the month of January. The new year has just started. And with that, many of us, tend to make some pretty big promises or goals for ourselves for the new year for 2023, which I think is honestly incredible, a great idea.
Hello and welcome back to the Psychology of Your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back. Welcome back to another episode of the psychology of your 20s, new listeners, old listeners. it's so great to have you here. So great to have you here for this super exciting topic that I am so pumped to talk about today. And that is the psychology of New Year's resolutions. There was no better time to talk about this than now. 2023 is right around the corner. Maybe you're listening to this in the month of January. The new year has just started. And with that, many of us, tend to make some pretty big promises or goals for ourselves for the new year for 2023, which I think is honestly incredible, a great idea.|||大家好，欢迎回到《二十岁心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个探讨我们二十岁时经历的一些重大生活变化和转变及其对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回来。欢迎收听《二十岁心理学》的又一期节目，新听友们，老听友们。很高兴你们能来到这里。很高兴你们能来听这个让我今天感到无比兴奋的主题。那就是新年决心的心理学。没有比现在更好的时机来讨论这个话题了。2023年就在眼前。也许你是在一月份收听这期节目。新的一年刚刚开始。随之而来的是，我们许多人往往会为新的一年，为2023年给自己许下一些非常重大的承诺或设定目标，老实说，我认为这真是不可思议，是个绝佳的主意。
I think that New Year's resolutions are a really kind of positive thing to reflect on and to set for ourselves as we enter into a new chapter. You know, they're all about self-improvement and agency and growth, which I think also really embodies this show. So I'm a big fan and if you are setting New Year's resolutions this year, I want you to succeed. So today we are going to break down the history and also the psychology behind New Year's resolutions, why it is that we set them to begin with, why they often fail, but also what we can learn from our failures and the failure of New Year's resolution.
I think that New Year's resolutions are a really kind of positive thing to reflect on and to set for ourselves as we enter into a new chapter. You know, they're all about self-improvement and agency and growth, which I think also really embodies this show. So I'm a big fan and if you are setting New Year's resolutions this year, I want you to succeed. So today we are going to break down the history and also the psychology behind New Year's resolutions, why it is that we set them to begin with, why they often fail, but also what we can learn from our failures and the failure of New Year's resolution.|||我认为新年决心确实是一种非常积极的事情，在我们迈入新篇章时用来反思并为自己设定目标。你知道，它们完全关乎自我提升、自主性和成长，我认为这也真正体现了本节目录制的初衷。所以我非常支持这一点，如果你今年正在设定新年决心，我希望你能成功。因此，今天我们将剖析新年背后的历史以及新年决心背后的心理学，我们为什么要在一开始设定它们，为什么它们经常失败，以及我们能从我们的失败和新年决心的失败中学到什么。
so that we can succeed so that we can see our New Year's resolutions through. Essentially, what I really want to understand and explain in today's episode is what it is that determines the success of a New Year's resolution. There is so much fascinating research behind this, so many interesting concepts like Roman philosophy, self-efficacy and self-improvement theory, even a discussion. of social norms and so much more. So I am so excited to kind of jump into this first episode of the New Year series, perhaps the first episode of 2023. It's going to be an amazing year. And what a great way to kick it off with a discussion about New Year's resolutions. So let's get into it and learn
so that we can succeed so that we can see our New Year's resolutions through. Essentially, what I really want to understand and explain in today's episode is what it is that determines the success of a New Year's resolution. There is so much fascinating research behind this, so many interesting concepts like Roman philosophy, self-efficacy and self-improvement theory, even a discussion. of social norms and so much more. So I am so excited to kind of jump into this first episode of the New Year series, perhaps the first episode of 2023. It's going to be an amazing year. And what a great way to kick it off with a discussion about New Year's resolutions. So let's get into it and learn|||以便我们能够成功，以便我们能够坚持贯彻我们的新年决心。本质上，我真正想在今天的节目中理解和解释的是，究竟是什么决定了一个新年决心的成功。这背后有如此多引人入胜的研究，有那么多有趣的概念，比如古罗马哲学、自我效能感和自我提升理论，甚至还有对社会规范的讨论等等。所以我非常兴奋能够开始新年系列的这第一期节目，也许是2023年的第一期节目。这将是精彩的一年。以讨论新年决心作为开端，真是太棒了。因此，让我们切入正题，来了解
all that there is to know about New Year's resolutions and hopefully learn how we can apply some of the theory, some of the psychology to our own goals so that we can be successful at the end of the day. So of course, as we always do at the beginning of each episode, we want to break down some of the history behind New Year's resolutions and get our basics down pat before jumping into the psychology and the explanations behind why this concept, this idea of making promises to ourselves at the beginning of the new year, why it even exists. So the origin of making New Year's resolutions, it rests with the Babylonians. For those of you who do not know who these people are, I didn't know who they were, but they were an ancient group of people who lived
all that there is to know about New Year's resolutions and hopefully learn how we can apply some of the theory, some of the psychology to our own goals so that we can be successful at the end of the day. So of course, as we always do at the beginning of each episode, we want to break down some of the history behind New Year's resolutions and get our basics down pat before jumping into the psychology and the explanations behind why this concept, this idea of making promises to ourselves at the beginning of the new year, why it even exists. So the origin of making New Year's resolutions, it rests with the Babylonians. For those of you who do not know who these people are, I didn't know who they were, but they were an ancient group of people who lived|||关于新年决心的一切，并希望了解我们如何将其中的一些理论、一些心理学知识应用到我们自己的目标中，以便我们最终能够取得成功。当然，正如我们在每期节目开始时惯常做的那样，在深入探讨心理学以及解释为什么会存在“在新年初对自己许下诺言”这一概念和想法背后的原因之前，我们首先要剖析一下新年决心背后的部分历史，并把基础知识掌握透彻。因此，许下新年决心的起源要追溯到巴比伦人。对于你们当中不知道这些人是谁的人来说（我以前也不知道他们是谁），他们是一个古代人群，生活在
in present-day Iraq from, I think, like 2,000 to 400 BC. And many historians trace the beginnings and the existence of New Year's resolutions back to this group. So these people would reportedly make promises to the gods in hopes that they would earn good favour in the coming year. So, for example, they might make a promise that they're going to have the most successful harvest they've ever seen or be a really good partner or a really good husband or wife. And by succeeding in that, by fulfilling that goal, that ambition, they all. almost demonstrated to the gods that they were true to their word, that they were, had integrity,
in present-day Iraq from, I think, like 2,000 to 400 BC. And many historians trace the beginnings and the existence of New Year's resolutions back to this group. So these people would reportedly make promises to the gods in hopes that they would earn good favour in the coming year. So, for example, they might make a promise that they're going to have the most successful harvest they've ever seen or be a really good partner or a really good husband or wife. And by succeeding in that, by fulfilling that goal, that ambition, they all. almost demonstrated to the gods that they were true to their word, that they were, had integrity,|||如今的伊拉克，时间大约在公元前2000年至400年左右。许多历史学家将新年决心的起源和存在追溯到这个群体。据报道，这些人会向神灵许下诺言，希望能在来年赢得神灵的青睐。例如，他们可能会许下诺言，承诺获得他们见过的最成功的丰收，或者成为一个真正优秀的伴侣、一个真正优秀的丈夫或妻子。通过实现这一目标、完成这一宏愿，他们几乎向神灵证明了他们是言而有信的，他们是正直的，
that they were good people, and as a result, they would receive good favour, good karma from these same gods. Although I don't think that we make our modern day resolutions to the gods per se, the new year is still, and obviously, a very important and somewhat spiritual time that represents so many things, but mostly new beginnings, the future, or a new chapter in our lives. Interestingly, this is, I think, a very common meaning. It's applied across different cultures. The month of January is actually named after the god Janus, who was the god of new beginnings. So we can see that there is this reverence placed on the new year throughout many cultures and throughout many time periods. I think as humans, we really crave the comfort of meaning and
that they were good people, and as a result, they would receive good favour, good karma from these same gods. Although I don't think that we make our modern day resolutions to the gods per se, the new year is still, and obviously, a very important and somewhat spiritual time that represents so many things, but mostly new beginnings, the future, or a new chapter in our lives. Interestingly, this is, I think, a very common meaning. It's applied across different cultures. The month of January is actually named after the god Janus, who was the god of new beginnings. So we can see that there is this reverence placed on the new year throughout many cultures and throughout many time periods. I think as humans, we really crave the comfort of meaning and|||他们是好人，因此，他们会从这些神灵那里获得好感和善报。尽管我认为我们现代人许下的新年决心本身并不是向神灵许下的，但新的一年仍然（而且显然是）一个非常重要且带有一点精神色彩的时刻，它代表了许许多多的事物，但最主要的是代表着新的开始、未来，或者我们生活中的新篇章。有趣的是，我认为这是一个非常普遍的含义。它适用于不同的文化。一月份（January）其实是以雅努斯（Janus）神命名的，他就是新开始之神。因此我们可以看到，在许多文化和许多历史时期中，人们对新的一年都抱有这种崇敬之情。我认为作为人类，我们真的很渴望意义和
tradition. And the new year is able to bring both of these things and offer somewhat of a dedicated time for reflection and contemplation of what we want from this new period of our lives. And you know, it often involves a pretty big celebration as well, you know, fireworks, champagne and all of that. But more than that, I think it provides a dedicated time for looking back, feeling grateful, nostalgic, and perhaps also thinking about what it is about our lives that may be missing something, where we feel we may be lacking or dissatisfied, where we can improve, whilst also being hopeful for the future and invest it in the ways that we can better ourselves. We tend to set resolutions at this time of the year because the new year in particular
tradition. And the new year is able to bring both of these things and offer somewhat of a dedicated time for reflection and contemplation of what we want from this new period of our lives. And you know, it often involves a pretty big celebration as well, you know, fireworks, champagne and all of that. But more than that, I think it provides a dedicated time for looking back, feeling grateful, nostalgic, and perhaps also thinking about what it is about our lives that may be missing something, where we feel we may be lacking or dissatisfied, where we can improve, whilst also being hopeful for the future and invest it in the ways that we can better ourselves. We tend to set resolutions at this time of the year because the new year in particular|||传统的慰藉。而新的一年能够将这两者结合起来，并提供一段专门的时间，让我们反思和沉思我们希望从这一段崭新的生活时期中获得什么。你知道，这通常还伴随着相当盛大的庆祝活动，比如烟花、香槟等等。但不仅于此，我认为它提供了一个专属时间，让我们回顾过去、心怀感恩、产生怀旧之情，也许还能思考我们生活中的什么地方可能有所缺失，我们在哪些方面可能感到有所欠缺或不满意，我们在哪些地方可以改进，同时对未来充满希望，并投入到能够完善自我的方式中去。我们倾向于在每年的这个时候设定决心，因为新的一年尤其
serves as this cyclical marker of time during which we can reevaluate and take inventory on our lives. And the drive for making resolutions is very much motivated by this punctuation in time which activates our hopes and our expectations for what we want to achieve going forward. So this psychologist, her name is Dollym. Dr. Strongen, she had a really good explanation for this that I thought would be super relevant when we're talking about why it is that the new year really sparks this desire to change up our lives. And she says that the new year, what it does is give us, gives us a kind of a sense
serves as this cyclical marker of time during which we can reevaluate and take inventory on our lives. And the drive for making resolutions is very much motivated by this punctuation in time which activates our hopes and our expectations for what we want to achieve going forward. So this psychologist, her name is Dollym. Dr. Strongen, she had a really good explanation for this that I thought would be super relevant when we're talking about why it is that the new year really sparks this desire to change up our lives. And she says that the new year, what it does is give us, gives us a kind of a sense|||充当了时间的周期性标志，在此期间我们可以重新评估并盘点我们的生活。而下定决心做某事的动力，很大程度上是由时间上的这个节点所激发的，它激活了我们对未来想要实现的目标的希望和期待。所以这位心理学家，她的名字叫多莉姆（Dollym）。斯特朗根博士（Dr. Strongen）对此有一个非常精彩的解释，我认为当我们讨论为什么新的一年真正会激发这种改变生活的愿望时，这个解释会超级贴切。她说，新的一年所做的事情是赋予我们一种
of renewal. And it causes us to think about areas in our lives where we want to improve. And this kind of distinct start of a new chapter of a new year, you know, the clock kind of ticks over into a new calendar, it feels like a natural time to make this change. There is really no better time than the beginning of a new year. And I think this is the marvel and also the significance of a new year for making massive changes to our everyday lives and I guess our overall lifestyle. When we think of New Year's resolutions, I think a few typical categories or examples often come to mind. And there's actually been research on this, on these very categories, these common categories that we see. So this woman, Caitlin Woolie from Cornell, she did some research
of renewal. And it causes us to think about areas in our lives where we want to improve. And this kind of distinct start of a new chapter of a new year, you know, the clock kind of ticks over into a new calendar, it feels like a natural time to make this change. There is really no better time than the beginning of a new year. And I think this is the marvel and also the significance of a new year for making massive changes to our everyday lives and I guess our overall lifestyle. When we think of New Year's resolutions, I think a few typical categories or examples often come to mind. And there's actually been research on this, on these very categories, these common categories that we see. So this woman, Caitlin Woolie from Cornell, she did some research|||焕然一新的感觉。它促使我们思考生活中那些我们希望改进的领域。而这种新一年新篇章的清晰起点，你知道，时钟滴答作响跨入新的日历，感觉这就是做出这种改变的自然时机。真的没有比新年的开始更好的时机了。我认为这就是新的一年对于彻底改变我们的日常生活以及我想我们的整体生活方式所具有的奇妙之处和重大意义。当我们想到新年决心时，我想脑海中经常会浮现出几个典型的类别或例子。事实上，关于这一点，关于我们看到的这些确切的类别、这些常见的类别，已经有过相关的研究。所以这位来自康奈尔大学的女性凯特琳·伍利（Caitlin Woolie），她做了一些研究
into New Year's resolutions and she wanted to find out what were the most common types of resolutions. I don't think this is a surprise to anyone. But the majority overwhelmingly, I think it was as high as like 55, 56% of resolutions were health-related. So wanting to exercise more, eat healthy, lose weight, those were by far the most common New Year's resolutions reported. Then we have work-related and financial-related kind of resolutions at about 35%. So a lot of people reported that they are going into the new year, wanting to save money, get out of debt, get organized by a house, these kind of financial and
into New Year's resolutions and she wanted to find out what were the most common types of resolutions. I don't think this is a surprise to anyone. But the majority overwhelmingly, I think it was as high as like 55, 56% of resolutions were health-related. So wanting to exercise more, eat healthy, lose weight, those were by far the most common New Year's resolutions reported. Then we have work-related and financial-related kind of resolutions at about 35%. So a lot of people reported that they are going into the new year, wanting to save money, get out of debt, get organized by a house, these kind of financial and|||关于新年决心的研究，她想弄清楚最常见的新年决心类型是什么。我想这对任何人来说都不会感到意外。但绝大多数（压倒性的多数），我想高达百分之五十五、五十六的决心都与健康有关。所以想要多锻炼、健康饮食、减肥，到目前为止，这些是报道最多的新年决心。然后是与工作相关和与财务相关的决心，大约占35%。因此，许多人报告说，他们进入新的一年时，想要存钱、摆脱债务、井井有条地买一套房子，诸如此类的财务和
work-related ambitions that they have. And then we also have these social goals. These accounted for about 5 to 10% overall. You know, goals like spending more time with family, making more friends, making time for romance, going on dates, meeting a partner. These were also a pretty big category of New Year's resolutions. I don't think I was surprised at all to hear how many resolutions or goals we make at the start of a new year have to do with our physical health and our physical appearance, mainly just because I think it is a huge source of just general insecurity for many of us, for many, many people. And these goals can be super varied, but they're often focused on things like feeling better in our bodies,
work-related ambitions that they have. And then we also have these social goals. These accounted for about 5 to 5 to 10% overall. You know, goals like spending more time with family, making more friends, making time for romance, going on dates, meeting a partner. These were also a pretty big category of New Year's resolutions. I don't think I was surprised at all to hear how many resolutions or goals we make at the start of a new year have to do with our physical health and our physical appearance, mainly just because I think it is a huge source of just general insecurity for many of us, for many, many people. And these goals can be super varied, but they're often focused on things like feeling better in our bodies,|||与工作相关的雄心壮志。然后我们还有这些社交目标。这些总体上约占5%到10%。你知道，诸如花更多时间陪伴家人、结交更多朋友、腾出时间谈恋爱、约会、结识伴侣等目标。这些也是相当大一类的新年决心。当听到我们在新年伊始许下的许多决心或设定的目标都与我们的身体健康和外表有关时，我一点也不感到惊讶，主要是因为我认为这对于我们许多人、许许多多的人来说，是普遍缺乏安全感的一个巨大来源。这些目标可以千差万别，但它们通常集中在诸如感觉自己的身体状态更好等方面，
maybe being able to accomplish a certain physical feat like a half marathon. Sometimes they have a lot to do with our eating and our diet, but of course also on how we look. Fitness is obviously a part of this, but I definitely have a bit of a bone to pick with goals that are focused on weight loss just because I actually think they're really hard to achieve, especially with the pressure and the hype of a new year. We get so excited about this.
maybe being able to accomplish a certain physical feat like a half marathon. Sometimes they have a lot to do with our eating and our diet, but of course also on how we look. Fitness is obviously a part of this, but I definitely have a bit of a bone to pick with goals that are focused on weight loss just because I actually think they're really hard to achieve, especially with the pressure and the hype of a new year. We get so excited about this.|||也许能够完成某种身体壮举，比如半程马拉松。有时它们与我们的饮食和日常饮食有很大关系，但当然也与我们的外表有关。健身显然是其中的一部分，但我对那些专注于减肥的目标绝对有点意见，因为我实际上认为它们真的很难实现，尤其是在新年的压力和炒作之下。我们对此感到非常兴奋。
We imagine how we're going to look, you know, what it's going to feel like. We don't understand the investment that it sometimes takes. And I've been seeing New Year's resolutions about weight loss everywhere, all over my TikTok right now. And it's kind of what inspired me to do this episode because I began thinking about my own New Year's expectations or goals for 2020. and I can honestly say I think this is the first year that my New Year's resolutions are not focused on what I look like or, you know, my body, which is like so shocking to me. I think that they have been focused on that for as long as I can remember. There's no shame if that is your New Year's resolution. You know, it's your body, it's your choice. As long as you're going into it with a healthy and sustainable mindset, go for it. It's honestly your life. And if that's going to make you happier, that's fantastic that
We imagine how we're going to look, you know, what it's going to feel like. We don't understand the investment that it sometimes takes. And I've been seeing New Year's resolutions about weight loss everywhere, all over my TikTok right now. And it's kind of what inspired me to do this episode because I began thinking about my own New Year's expectations or goals for 2020. and I can honestly say I think this is the first year that my New Year's resolutions are not focused on what I look like or, you know, my body, which is like so shocking to me. I think that they have been focused on that for as long as I can remember. There's no shame if that is your New Year's resolution. You know, it's your body, it's your choice. As long as you're going into it with a healthy and sustainable mindset, go for it. It's honestly your life. And if that's going to make you happier, that's fantastic that|||我们想象着自己会是什么样子，你知道，那种感觉会是怎样的。我们并不了解这有时需要付出多少投入。我到处都能看到关于减肥的新年决心，现在我的TikTok到处都是。这也是启发我做这期节目的原因，因为我开始思考自己对2020年的新年期望或目标，我可以诚实地说，我认为这是我多年来第一年的新年决心没有把重点放在我的外表或者说我的身材上，这对我来说简直太震撼了。我想记忆中它们一直都聚焦于此。如果那是你的新年决心，也没什么好羞耻的。你知道，这是你的身体，这是你的选择。只要你带着健康和可持续的心态去面对它，那就放手去做吧。老实说，这是你的人生。如果这能让你更开心，那真是太棒了，
you have, you know, decided to focus on that for your health and as an element of your health for 2023. But I think there are other health goals as well that are perhaps more achievable and I would say more holistic. You know, maybe your New Year's resolution is to stop drinking or to drink less. That's one of mine. Next year, I really, I honestly do not have the time to be hung over as much as I was last year and I just kind of want to cut back. So that's one of my news resolutions. Another one I see quite often is to like walk 10,000 steps a day. I think these are like that one in particular that 10,000 step one is a lot more achievable than setting some obscure weight loss goal because it's achievable. It can be integrated into your life and it affects so
you have, you know, decided to focus on that for your health and as an element of your health for 2023. But I think there are other health goals as well that are perhaps more achievable and I would say more holistic. You know, maybe your New Year's resolution is to stop drinking or to drink less. That's one of mine. Next year, I really, I honestly do not have the time to be hung over as much as I was last year and I just kind of want to cut back. So that's one of my news resolutions. Another one I see quite often is to like walk 10,000 steps a day. I think these are like that one in particular that 10,000 step one is a lot more achievable than setting some obscure weight loss goal because it's achievable. It can be integrated into your life and it affects so|||你知道，你已经决定在2023年为了健康以及作为健康的一个要素而专注于此。但我认为还有其他一些健康目标可能更容易实现，而且我认为也更全面。你知道，也许你的新年决心是戒酒或减少饮酒。这也是我的决心之一。明年，我真的、老实说我没有那么多时间像去年那样经常宿醉了，我只是想少喝一点。所以这是我的新年决心之一。我经常看到的另一个决心是每天走一万步。我认为这些——尤其是每天走一万步的那一个——比设定一些晦涩难懂的减肥目标要容易实现得多，因为它是可以做到的。它可以融入你的生活，并且会产生如此之多的
much more than just, you know, the number on a scale. It affects the time we spent outdoors. It affects how we feel in our body. It affects our cardiovascular health. So I think it's a much more well-rounded goal. Another big category that obviously I'm a huge fan of is the mental health resolutions, the mental health goals. These are mainly focused on our emotional well-being and the things that we can do to shift our mindset and our mental perspective. You know, there are the normal ones like going to therapy, trying to perhaps prioritize your boundaries and your space, but there are some others that I think are fantastic,
much more than just, you know, the number on a scale. It affects the time we spent outdoors. It affects how we feel in our body. It affects our cardiovascular health. So I think it's a much more well-rounded goal. Another big category that obviously I'm a huge fan of is the mental health resolutions, the mental health goals. These are mainly focused on our emotional well-being and the things that we can do to shift our mindset and our mental perspective. You know, there are the normal ones like going to therapy, trying to perhaps prioritize your boundaries and your space, but there are some others that I think are fantastic,|||不仅仅是（你知道的）体重秤上的数字。它影响我们在户外度过的时间。它影响我们身体的感觉。它影响我们的心血管健康。所以我认为这是一个更全面的目标。另一个显而易见我非常热衷的大类别是心理健康决心、心理健康目标。这些主要集中在我们的情感健康以及我们为了改变心态和精神视角而可以做的事情上。你知道，有一些常规的做法，比如去看心理治疗师，试着把你的界限和空间放在首位，但还有一些其他的我认为非常棒，
like reducing your screen time. Our exposure to social media and to just the internet and screens in general can have such a strange and nuanced effect on our mental health. So I think reducing screen time is such a fantastic goal, if that is your priority. Reading more, that's an amazing one. It's highly achievable. And another one I saw was to get at least 20 minutes of sun or outdoors time a day. That is such an amazing New Year's resolution. Honestly, it's so easy to integrate into our lives, especially if you live somewhere like Australia where, you know, the weather is sometimes bad, but in general.
like reducing your screen time. Our exposure to social media and to just the internet and screens in general can have such a strange and nuanced effect on our mental health. So I think reducing screen time is such a fantastic goal, if that is your priority. Reading more, that's an amazing one. It's highly achievable. And another one I saw was to get at least 20 minutes of sun or outdoors time a day. That is such an amazing New Year's resolution. Honestly, it's so easy to integrate into our lives, especially if you live somewhere like Australia where, you know, the weather is sometimes bad, but in general.|||比如减少你的屏幕使用时间。我们接触社交媒体以及整个互联网和屏幕，可能会对我们的心理健康产生一种奇怪而微妙的影响。所以我认为减少屏幕时间是一个非常棒的目标，如果那是你的首要任务的话。多读书，这是一个了不起的习惯。它非常容易实现。我看到的另一个目标是每天至少有20分钟的阳光照射或户外活动时间。这是一个非常棒的新年决心。老实说，它很容易融入我们的生活，特别是如果你住在像澳大利亚这样（你知道的）天气有时不太好，但总体而言
general, most of the time, bearable. And it also allows us to incorporate many of the health benefits of being in nature. So I think that if that is something you want to focus on, what an amazing goal. A couple others, just to briefly mention, we talked about financial goals, you know, saving for a particular reason. Maybe you want to buy a house or go on a big trip. And then there are some other like niche goals and achievements, like, I don't know, wanting to climb Everest or to knit 50 mini jackets for your cats, start a business, start a podcast. That one sounds pretty familiar. And these kind of goals are often super unique and I would say not shared by many people which at times on one hand I think can make it harder to form community but it also makes it so much
general, most of the time, bearable. And it also allows us to incorporate many of the health benefits of being in nature. So I think that if that is something you want to focus on, what an amazing goal. A couple others, just to briefly mention, we talked about financial goals, you know, saving for a particular reason. Maybe you want to buy a house or go on a big trip. And then there are some other like niche goals and achievements, like, I don't know, wanting to climb Everest or to knit 50 mini jackets for your cats, start a business, start a podcast. That one sounds pretty familiar. And these kind of goals are often super unique and I would say not shared by many people which at times on one hand I think can make it harder to form community but it also makes it so much|||一般来说，大多数时候都还可以忍受的地方。它还允许我们结合身处大自然中的诸多健康益处。所以我认为如果那是你想关注的事情，这是一个多么棒的目标啊。另外几个，简单提一下，我们讨论过财务目标，你知道，为了某个特定的原因存钱。也许你想买一套房子或进行一次大旅行。然后还有一些其他类似小众的目标和成就，比如，我不知道，想要登顶珠穆朗玛峰，或者为你的猫织50件迷你夹克，创业，开办一个播客。那个听起来挺耳熟的。这类目标通常超级独特，而且我想说，很多人并没有这种目标，有时一方面我认为这会使建立社群变得更加困难，但这也让它变得
more worthwhile because fewer people have that goal and achieving it is going to be so much more sweet and such an amazing feeling. Obviously this is not an exhaustive list. I honestly think that any facet of our lives where we're perhaps not quite satisfied or fulfilled or would like to do better can be made into a goal. And sometimes the significance of a new year, of a new leaf, a new chapter, but also the explicit kind of start date and point from which to track our progress can be a huge enabler of our success. But let's now tackle the psychology behind how we can create realistic New Year's resolutions and almost offer a bit of an equation for success so that we can start 2023 with the best versions of ourselves in mind. So we have explained some of the history,
more worthwhile because fewer people have that goal and achieving it is going to be so much more sweet and such an amazing feeling. Obviously this is not an exhaustive list. I honestly think that any facet of our lives where we're perhaps not quite satisfied or fulfilled or would like to do better can be made into a goal. And sometimes the significance of a new year, of a new leaf, a new chapter, but also the explicit kind of start date and point from which to track our progress can be a huge enabler of our success. But let's now tackle the psychology behind how we can create realistic New Year's resolutions and almost offer a bit of an equation for success so that we can start 2023 with the best versions of ourselves in mind. So we have explained some of the history,|||更加值得，因为拥有这个目标的人更少，而实现它将会更加甜蜜，那种感觉也会无比美妙。显然，这不是一份详尽无遗的清单。老实说，我认为我们生活中任何可能不太满意、不够充实或想要做得更好的方面，都可以转化为一个目标。有时，新的一年、翻开新的一页、开启新篇章的意义，以及用明确的开始日期和跟踪我们进展的起点，都可以成为我们成功的巨大助推器。但现在，让我们来探讨如何制定切实可行的新年决心的心理学，并几乎提供一个成功的公式，以便我们在开启2023年时，脑海中浮现出最好的自己。所以我们已经解释了一些历史，
the categories, the traditions behind New Year's resolutions, but now to the psychology. What is it about the new year that causes us to have these elaborate and grand expectations for ourselves to set these resolutions? I think as humans, we are naturally and innately very attuned to self-improvement. It is very much part of our complexity and a unique aspect of our species, that we have this capacity to consider the future and ourselves within it. And with that, we tend to imagine versions of ourselves that do not yet exist, ones that might be better. Because of this unique ability, we're able to set goals and objectives that lead to better versions of ourselves. That is the premise of New Year's resolutions. The idea, though,
the categories, the traditions behind New Year's resolutions, but now to the psychology. What is it about the new year that causes us to have these elaborate and grand expectations for ourselves to set these resolutions? I think as humans, we are naturally and innately very attuned to self-improvement. It is very much part of our complexity and a unique aspect of our species, that we have this capacity to consider the future and ourselves within it. And with that, we tend to imagine versions of ourselves that do not yet exist, ones that might be better. Because of this unique ability, we're able to set goals and objectives that lead to better versions of ourselves. That is the premise of New Year's resolutions. The idea, though,|||新年决心背后的类别、传统，但现在我们要谈谈心理学。新的一年究竟有什么魔力，让我们对自己抱有如此精心设计和宏大的期望，去设定这些决心？我认为作为人类，我们天生就对自我提升非常敏感。这很大程度上是我们复杂性的一部分，也是我们物种的一个独特之处，即我们有能力思考未来以及我们在其中的位置。正因如此，我们往往会想象那些尚未存在的、可能更好的自我版本。由于这种独特的能力，我们能够设定目标和宗旨，引导我们走向更好的自己。这就是新年决心的前提。不过，这个想法
of a New Year's resolution, it tends to rest on three fairly important psychological concepts. The first being personal development, the second being self-efficacy, and finally the idea of social norms. Personal development, it's all about looking inward and focusing on the ways to better yourself. It's so obvious how that has a relationship to New Year's resolutions. But essentially this, focus allows us to increase our self-awareness, our self-esteem, and to fulfill future aspirations that we may have for our lives. When we make a New Year's resolution, whatever it may be, we are channeling our personal development and our focus on personal growth and kind of, yeah, channeling that in a way that allows us to be productive and to live
of a New Year's resolution, it tends to rest on three fairly important psychological concepts. The first being personal development, the second being self-efficacy, and finally the idea of social norms. Personal development, it's all about looking inward and focusing on the ways to better yourself. It's so obvious how that has a relationship to New Year's resolutions. But essentially this, focus allows us to increase our self-awareness, our self-esteem, and to fulfill future aspirations that we may have for our lives. When we make a New Year's resolution, whatever it may be, we are channeling our personal development and our focus on personal growth and kind of, yeah, channeling that in a way that allows us to be productive and to live|||新年决心的概念往往建立在三个相当重要的心理概念基础之上。第一个是个人发展，第二个是自我效能感，最后是社会规范的概念。个人发展，完全是关于向内看并专注于如何完善自我。这与新年决心之间的关系是显而易见的。但本质上，这种专注使我们能够提高自我意识、自尊心，并实现我们对未来生活可能抱有的期望。当我们许下新年决心时，无论它是什么，我们都在引导我们的个人发展，并将重心放在个人成长上，并且，是的，以一种让我们能够高效生活并过上
a more fulfilled and satisfying life. Without this ability or the skills to reflect inwards and upwards, we can remain fairly stagnant and unsatisfied with our lives, which is why the new year is such an important time to make certain promises to ourselves, because they are focused on improving our lives in order to enhance the overall quality. So even if we don't fully realize our goals, the very act, I think, of just reflecting on where we want to improve, where we want to be, putting energy towards that is so valuable, because not only does it mean that we have a sense
a more fulfilled and satisfying life. Without this ability or the skills to reflect inwards and upwards, we can remain fairly stagnant and unsatisfied with our lives, which is why the new year is such an important time to make certain promises to ourselves, because they are focused on improving our lives in order to enhance the overall quality. So even if we don't fully realize our goals, the very act, I think, of just reflecting on where we want to improve, where we want to be, putting energy towards that is so valuable, because not only does it mean that we have a sense|||更加充实和满意生活的方式来引导这种能量。如果没有这种向内和向上反思的能力或技巧，我们的生活可能会停滞不前，并对现状感到不满意，这就是为什么新的一年是向自己许下某些承诺的如此重要的时刻，因为它们专注于改善我们的生活以提高整体质量。因此，即使我们没有完全实现我们的目标，我认为，仅仅是反思我们希望在哪些方面进行改进、希望达到什么状态、并为此投入精力的这一行为本身就非常有价值，因为这不仅意味着我们对未来有感知力
of the future and a sense of meaning, but we also have a desire to be better, which is in itself a very inherently valuable idea to have. The second psychological concept that I think is, perhaps even more important to consider in the context of New Year's resolutions is self-efficacy. So self-efficacy is at the very core, perhaps the central pillar to establishing goals for ourselves in the new year. Essentially, it refers to our belief in our capacity to execute the behaviours necessary to produce specific outcomes. So just to break that down a little bit more. It essentially encompasses our confidence that our behavior and our actions will be able to exert an influence over our environment and over our future so that we can achieve our goals.
of the future and a sense of meaning, but we also have a desire to be better, which is in itself a very inherently valuable idea to have. The second psychological concept that I think is, perhaps even more important to consider in the context of New Year's resolutions is self-efficacy. So self-efficacy is at the very core, perhaps the central pillar to establishing goals for ourselves in the new year. Essentially, it refers to our belief in our capacity to execute the behaviours necessary to produce specific outcomes. So just to break that down a little bit more. It essentially encompasses our confidence that our behavior and our actions will be able to exert an influence over our environment and over our future so that we can achieve our goals.|||并且有一种意义感，而且我们还有变得更好的渴望，这本身就是一个非常具有内在价值的想法。我认为在新年决心的背景下，第二个也许更需要考虑的心理学概念是自我效能感。因此，自我效能感是核心，也许是我们在新一年为自己设定目标的中心支柱。本质上，它是指我们对自身是否有能力执行产生特定结果所需的行为的信念。为了对此作进一步剖析。它基本上包含了这样一种信心：我们的行为和行动能够对我们的环境和未来产生影响，从而使我们能够实现我们的目标。
Without self-efficacy, without this belief in our ability to alter our lives, the idea of a New Year's resolution, it literally wouldn't exist. it wouldn't be anything but wishful thinking. That is what distinguishes the New Year's resolution from just, you know, a fantasy. It's that acknowledgement that what we want for our lives will require our effort. And therefore this belief that our actions, our behaviours will actually have some influence over whether or not we achieve a certain goal. You know, without self-efficacy, why would we even try?
Without self-efficacy, without this belief in our ability to alter our lives, the idea of a New Year's resolution, it literally wouldn't exist. it wouldn't be anything but wishful thinking. That is what distinguishes the New Year's resolution from just, you know, a fantasy. It's that acknowledgement that what we want for our lives will require our effort. And therefore this belief that our actions, our behaviours will actually have some influence over whether or not we achieve a certain goal. You know, without self-efficacy, why would we even try?|||如果没有自我效能感，如果没有这种相信自己能够改变生活的能力的信念，新年决心的概念实际上根本就不会存在。它除了是一厢情愿的想法之外什么也不是。这就是新年决心与单纯的（你知道的）幻想的区别所在。它是这样一种认知：我们对生活的诉求需要我们付出努力。因此，这种信念认为，我们的行动、我们的行为实际上会对我们能否实现某个目标产生一定的影响。你知道，如果没有自我效能感，我们为什么还要尝试呢？
There's no point trying. I think virtually all people can identify some form of goal that they have. However, I think where we go wrong is that most of us don't always think about the fact that putting these plans into action isn't as simple as we think. And self-efficacy is going to play a major role and how we approach this goal and how we approach this challenge. You know, people with stronger self-efficacy, they offer, recover really quickly from setbacks. They make a plan, they view problems as something to be
There's no point trying. I think virtually all people can identify some form of goal that they have. However, I think where we go wrong is that most of us don't always think about the fact that putting these plans into action isn't as simple as we think. And self-efficacy is going to play a major role and how we approach this goal and how we approach this challenge. You know, people with stronger self-efficacy, they offer, recover really quickly from setbacks. They make a plan, they view problems as something to be|||尝试毫无意义。我认为几乎所有人都能确定自己拥有某种形式的目标。然而，我认为我们出错的地方在于，我们大多数人并不总是考虑到这样一个事实：将这些计划付诸实践并不像我们想象的那么简单。自我效能感将在我们如何对待这个目标以及如何应对这个挑战方面发挥重要作用。你知道，自我效能感更强的人，他们通常能从挫折中非常迅速地恢复过来。他们制定计划，将问题视为需要
mastered, and they really are a lot more invested in their goals and they're invested in the activities that they are required to do to achieve these goals. In contrast, we see people who have lower or weaker self-efficacy tend to really avoid some of the challenging tasks and behaviours that are required, they focus a lot on the potential of failure and on the negative outcomes, and they quickly lose confidence in their personal abilities, right? Like they don't feel confident that they have the agency, they have the strength, they have the skills necessary to achieve their goal. Obviously, if you have set an ambitious New Year's resolution, whatever it may be, a strong
mastered, and they really are a lot more invested in their goals and they're invested in the activities that they are required to do to achieve these goals. In contrast, we see people who have lower or weaker self-efficacy tend to really avoid some of the challenging tasks and behaviours that are required, they focus a lot on the potential of failure and on the negative outcomes, and they quickly lose confidence in their personal abilities, right? Like they don't feel confident that they have the agency, they have the strength, they have the skills necessary to achieve their goal. Obviously, if you have set an ambitious New Year's resolution, whatever it may be, a strong|||克服的事情，而且他们确实对自己的目标投入了更多，并且投入到了实现这些目标所必需的活动中。相比之下，我们看到那些自我效能感较低或较弱的人往往会极力逃避一些所需的具有挑战性的任务和行为，他们极度关注失败的潜力和消极的结果，并且很快对自己的个人能力失去信心，对吧？就像他们不自信自己拥有实现目标所需的自主权、力量和技能一样。显然，如果你设定了一个雄心勃勃的新年决心，无论它是什么，强大的
sense of self-efficacy is going to be a great asset to achieving this goal. And importantly, self-efficacy, it's not something you're born with, right? It's actually something that you can develop and train within yourself. And there are a few ways to do that. Firstly, by celebrating your successes, by really consciously recognizing instances in which you have been able to influence your destiny or change in outcome, modeling. and observing the behaviours and stories of others, having those positive role models or mentors to kind of show you that this is possible.
sense of self-efficacy is going to be a great asset to achieving this goal. And importantly, self-efficacy, it's not something you're born with, right? It's actually something that you can develop and train within yourself. And there are a few ways to do that. Firstly, by celebrating your successes, by really consciously recognizing instances in which you have been able to influence your destiny or change in outcome, modeling. and observing the behaviours and stories of others, having those positive role models or mentors to kind of show you that this is possible.|||自我效能感都将是实现这一目标的巨大财富。重要的是，自我效能感并不是你天生就有的，对吧？它实际上是你可以在自己身上培养和训练的东西。有几种方法可以做到这一点。首先，通过庆祝你的成功，通过真正有意识地认出那些你能够影响命运或改变结果的实例，进行榜样学习。并观察他人的行为和故事，拥有那些积极的榜样或导师来向你展示这是可能的。
And another way is to seek out positive feedback and positive affirmations. Obviously, when you hear positive feedback from others, that can really help improve your sense of self-efficacy and not only that, but your sense that you are actually achieving your goal, that it is recognizable from the perspective of other people. You know, if your therapist tells you that you're doing a really good job
And another way is to seek out positive feedback and positive affirmations. Obviously, when you hear positive feedback from others, that can really help improve your sense of self-efficacy and not only that, but your sense that you are actually achieving your goal, that it is recognizable from the perspective of other people. You know, if your therapist tells you that you're doing a really good job|||另一种方法是寻找积极的反馈和积极的肯定。显然，当你听到来自他人的积极反馈时，这确实有助于提高你的自我效能感，不仅如此，还会增强你正在真正实现目标的感知，即从其他人的角度来看，这是可被认可的。你知道，如果你的治疗师告诉你，你做得非常好，
at prioritizing your mental health, that's setting boundaries, that's going to be so encouraging, and it's going to make you want to keep going. But in contrast, and on the other hand, negative feedback, negative comments can also have a pretty powerful undermining effect. So be conscious about who you share your goals and ambitions with. I don't think there is anything more demoralizing than someone telling you that what you're doing is not worth it or that you're going to fail. It's such a terrible, terrible feeling.
at prioritizing your mental health, that's setting boundaries, that's going to be so encouraging, and it's going to make you want to keep going. But in contrast, and on the other hand, negative feedback, negative comments can also have a pretty powerful undermining effect. So be conscious about who you share your goals and ambitions with. I don't think there is anything more demoralizing than someone telling you that what you're doing is not worth it or that you're going to fail. It's such a terrible, terrible feeling.|||在优先考虑你的心理健康方面，也就是在设定界限方面，那将是无比鼓舞人心的，并且会让你想要继续坚持下去。但相比之下，另一方面，消极的反馈、负面的评论也会产生相当强大的破坏作用。因此，对于与谁分享你的目标和雄心壮志，你要有清醒的认识。我认为没有什么比有人告诉你你所做的事情不值得或者你会失败更让人泄气的了。那真是一种可怕至极的感觉。
So if you want to succeed, you have to create a supportive environment that contains people who really believe in your abilities and they believe in your success. finally making a new year's resolution it's somewhat of a social norm these days right like a social norm being these kind of informal rules or expectations that we have it's very much influenced by what we see other people doing it gets to December early January and people start talking about their new year's resolutions and we feel like we should probably have a few of our own this is not a bad thing at all In fact, I think it's one of the more positive social norms that we've discussed on the show, because as we said, the primary reason for setting this kind of goal at the start of the year is for self-growth. So as long as we're not harming anyone, they seem to be overall a pretty positive thing.
So if you want to succeed, you have to create a supportive environment that contains people who really believe in your abilities and they believe in your success. finally making a new year's resolution it's somewhat of a social norm these days right like a social norm being these kind of informal rules or expectations that we have it's very much influenced by what we see other people doing it gets to December early January and people start talking about their new year's resolutions and we feel like we should probably have a few of our own this is not a bad thing at all In fact, I think it's one of the more positive social norms that we've discussed on the show, because as we said, the primary reason for setting this kind of goal at the start of the year is for self-growth. So as long as we're not harming anyone, they seem to be overall a pretty positive thing.|||所以如果你想成功，你必须创建一个支持性的环境，里面包含那些真正相信你的能力并且相信你能成功的人。最后，许下新年决心如今在某种程度上已经成为了一种社会规范，对吧？就像社会规范是我们所拥有的这种非正式规则或期望一样，它在很大程度上受到我们看到其他人所作所为的影响。到了十二月、一月初，人们开始谈论他们的新年决心，我们就会觉得我们大概也应该有几个自己的决心，这绝对不是一件坏事。事实上，我认为这是我们在节目中讨论过的更具积极性的社会规范之一，因为正如我们所说，在年初设定这种主要目标的原因是为了自我成长。因此，只要我们没有伤害任何人，它们总体上似乎是一件非常积极的事情。
Well, at least that's what we think is the case. But it might actually be that New Year's resolutions are neither positive or negative, especially when we consider how many of us and how many of our resolutions end up failing. And that is what I want to discuss next. Why is it that so many of our ambitions for the new year end up being forgotten by the second or third week of January? Every year in early January, millions and millions of us resolve to change something about our lives change something about our behavior, whether it is to get really fit, to eat better, to save money, spend more time with our friends, whatever it is. There is no denying that most
Well, at least that's what we think is the case. But it might actually be that New Year's resolutions are neither positive or negative, especially when we consider how many of us and how many of our resolutions end up failing. And that is what I want to discuss next. Why is it that so many of our ambitions for the new year end up being forgotten by the second or third week of January? Every year in early January, millions and millions of us resolve to change something about our lives change something about our behavior, whether it is to get really fit, to eat better, to save money, spend more time with our friends, whatever it is. There is no denying that most|||嗯，至少我们认为是这样的情况。但实际上，新年决心可能既不是积极的也不是消极的，特别是当我们考虑到我们中有多少人以及我们的多少决心最终以失败告终时。这正是我接下来要讨论的内容。为什么我们的许多新年宏愿最终在1月的前两三周就被遗忘了？每年1月初，数以百万计的我们下定决心要改变我们生活的某些方面，改变我们行为的某些方面，无论是变得非常健康、吃得更好、存钱、花更多时间陪朋友，还是其他什么。不可否认的是，大多数
of us have something in mind that we want to change in 2023. Here is the sad reality, though. For most of us, these New Year's resolutions are going to fall by the wayside within a few weeks. The best example I think of this, of the early failure of many resolutions, is thinking about how busy your gym is in the first weeks of January, yet by, you know, February they're normally back to usual. That's because we often get wrapped up in the excitement of setting the resolution of imagining the outcome without realizing how much commitment it can take. the easiest step to making a new year's resolution is telling yourself that you're going to do it, is making that promise and imagining the success, imagining your future body or your future financial situation or your amazing life, especially in that moment before we actually have to do some of the work. It is very easy to fantasize, but for anyone who's actually set
of us have something in mind that we want to change in 2023. Here is the sad reality, though. For most of us, these New Year's resolutions are going to fall by the wayside within a few weeks. The best example I think of this, of the early failure of many resolutions, is thinking about how busy your gym is in the first weeks of January, yet by, you know, February they're normally back to usual. That's because we often get wrapped up in the excitement of setting the resolution of imagining the outcome without realizing how much commitment it can take. the easiest step to making a new year's resolution is telling yourself that you're going to do it, is making that promise and imagining the success, imagining your future body or your future financial situation or your amazing life, especially in that moment before we actually have to do some of the work. It is very easy to fantasize, but for anyone who's actually set|||我们心里都有想要在2023年改变的事情。然而，以下是残酷的现实。对于我们大多数人来说，这些新年决心将在几周内付诸东流。我认为这（许多决心过早失败）最好的例子，就是想想在一月份的前几周你的健身房有多忙，然而到了（你知道的）二月份，它们通常又恢复了正常。那是因为我们经常沉浸在设定决心的兴奋中，沉浸在想象结果的喜悦中，却没有意识到这可能需要付出多少承诺。许下新年决心最简单的一步就是告诉自己你要去做了，就是做出那个承诺并想象成功，想象你未来的身材、未来的财务状况或你精彩的生活，尤其是在我们实际上不得不去做一些工作之前的那个时刻。幻想是非常容易的，但对于任何真正设定过
a new year's resolution, it's a lot harder to actually achieve that goal because it requires often a lot of tedious and persistent work. I don't really think it's even a goal, right, if it's easy to achieve. That's part of the allure of New Year's resolutions is that they are really large and grand and significant and they require that significance of the new year in order to begin. There are quite a few reasons I want to discuss as to why it's so difficult to stick to our New Year's resolutions, and many of these explanations have some pretty fascinating psychology attached. Firstly, a large amount of our daily behaviours tend to be motivated by what we see as unconscious
a new year's resolution, it's a lot harder to actually achieve that goal because it requires often a lot of tedious and persistent work. I don't really think it's even a goal, right, if it's easy to achieve. That's part of the allure of New Year's resolutions is that they are really large and grand and significant and they require that significance of the new year in order to begin. There are quite a few reasons I want to discuss as to why it's so difficult to stick to our New Year's resolutions, and many of these explanations have some pretty fascinating psychology attached. Firstly, a large amount of our daily behaviours tend to be motivated by what we see as unconscious|||新年决心的人来说，真正实现这个目标要困难得多，因为它通常需要大量枯燥且持久的工作。如果很容易实现，我真的不认为那甚至能算是一个目标，对吧？这也是新年决心的魅力所在，因为它们真的很大、很宏大、很有意义，并且它们需要新年那种特殊意义才能开始。我想讨论几个原因，解释为什么坚持新年决心如此困难，而其中许多解释都附带了一些非常迷人的心理学原理。首先，我们的大量日常行为往往是由我们认为的无意识驱动的
and automatic habits that have in many ways been in. ingrained in us since our childhood, since our teenage years. We unconsciously reach for the same types of food, we wake up at the same time, we see the same people, we use the same forms of transport because these actions and these behaviours have become so habitual and it makes it really difficult to change. And over time, these repetitive ways of behaving tend to become very much automatically queued by the situations that we're in and they're completely independent
and automatic habits that have in many ways been in. ingrained in us since our childhood, since our teenage years. We unconsciously reach for the same types of food, we wake up at the same time, we see the same people, we use the same forms of transport because these actions and these behaviours have become so habitual and it makes it really difficult to change. And over time, these repetitive ways of behaving tend to become very much automatically queued by the situations that we're in and they're completely independent|||和自动习惯所驱动的，这些习惯在很多方面从我们的童年、从我们的青少年时期起就根深蒂固在我们体内。我们不知不觉地去拿同一种食物，我们在同一时间醒来，我们见同样的人，我们使用同一种交通工具，因为这些动作和这些行为已经变得如此习以为常，以至于很难改变。随着时间的推移，这些重复的行为方式往往会非常自发地被我们所处的环境所触发，并且它们完全独立于
from our deliberate thought processes so much of what we do on a day-to-day basis we do without thinking when we set a New Year's resolution though that is a very deliberate a very conscious action a very conscious thought
from our deliberate thought processes so much of what we do on a day-to-day basis we do without thinking when we set a New Year's resolution though that is a very deliberate a very conscious action a very conscious thought|||我们的刻意思考过程，我们在日常生活中做的很多事情都是不经过大脑的。然而，当我们设定新年决心时，那是一个非常刻意的、非常有意识的行动，是一个非常清醒的想法，
and it can be really difficult to integrate this conscious and deliberate thing we want to achieve into our daily lives and into our daily lives that are filled with automatic behaviours and unconscious habits. Because they are so hard to integrate and because a lot of our resolutions often require almost rewriting or rewiring our automatic behaviours, it takes a lot of conscious energy to uphold these resolutions, which is why they often fail. This explains why achieving our New Year's resolutions is not just about pure determination.
and it can be really difficult to integrate this conscious and deliberate thing we want to achieve into our daily lives and into our daily lives that are filled with automatic behaviours and unconscious habits. Because they are so hard to integrate and because a lot of our resolutions often require almost rewriting or rewiring our automatic behaviors, it takes a lot of conscious energy to uphold these resolutions, which is why they often fail. This explains why achieving our New Year's resolutions is not just about pure determination.|||要把我们想要实现的这种有意识和刻意的事情融入到我们的日常生活以及充满自动行为和无意识习惯的日常生活中，可能会非常困难。由于它们很难融入，而且我们的许多决心往往几乎需要重写或重新布线我们的自动行为，因此维持这些决心需要消耗大量的有意识精力，这就是它们经常失败的原因。这就解释了为什么实现新年决心不仅仅取决于纯粹的决心。
It's not just about how much you want it. The act of achieving any goal requires a lot of intense, concentrated energy. And more than that, it requires rewriting unconscious behaviors you've probably followed for years and years and years. Often we don't really map out or think about, what it's going to take to accomplish a goal. And instead we rely very much so on that excitement of the new year as the thing that's going to push us to accomplish this goal, this buzz, this excitement, this like expectation. And then that buzz wears off. Or maybe you
It's not just about how much you want it. The act of achieving any goal requires a lot of intense, concentrated energy. And more than that, it requires rewriting unconscious behaviors you've probably followed for years and years and years. Often we don't really map out or think about, what it's going to take to accomplish a goal. And instead we rely very much so on that excitement of the new year as the thing that's going to push us to accomplish this goal, this buzz, this excitement, this like expectation. And then that buzz wears off. Or maybe you|||这不仅仅取决于你有多么渴望它。实现任何目标的行为都需要大量强烈的、集中的精力。不仅如此，它还需要重写你可能已经遵循了多年、多年、多年的无意识行为。通常我们并没有真正规划或思考过，完成一个目标需要付出什么。相反，我们极大地依赖于新年的那种兴奋感，将其作为推动我们完成这个目标的动力，这种兴奋、这种狂热、这种类似于期望的东西。然后那种狂热感就消退了。或者也许你
realize that actually you set a few unrealistic expectations for yourself. For example, you know, if you've decided that 2023, you're going to run a marathon and and you've bought tickets for a race in April, it's highly unlikely that you're going to do that. You really set yourself up to fail because you haven't been honest or realistic with yourself. The cycle of making and subsequently breaking resolutions, it boils down to one core issue or concept,
realize that actually you set a few unrealistic expectations for yourself. For example, you know, if you've decided that 2023, you're going to run a marathon and and you've bought tickets for a race in April, it's highly unlikely that you're going to do that. You really set yourself up to fail because you haven't been honest or realistic with yourself. The cycle of making and subsequently breaking resolutions, it boils down to one core issue or concept,|||意识到实际上你为自己设定了一些不切实际的期望。例如，你知道，如果你决定在2023年去跑马拉松，并且你已经买了一场四月份比赛的门票，你几乎不可能做到这一点。你真的是在为自己的失败做铺垫，因为你对自己并不诚实，也不现实。许下决心随后又打破决心的循环，归根结底是一个核心问题或概念，
and that is honesty. Being honest with yourself about what it is, you want, why you want to achieve it and how achievable it is. So before you set your resolution for 2023, it's really important to ask yourself some of those core questions and be honest with yourself in answering them. Why is it that this goal is important to you? And how do you imagine it's going to make your life better? Really, really think about that. is the outcome of your resolution? Is it going to be enough to motivate you to do the things that you need to do?
and that is honesty. Being honest with yourself about what it is, you want, why you want to achieve it and how achievable it is. So before you set your resolution for 2023, it's really important to ask yourself some of those core questions and be honest with yourself in answering them. Why is it that this goal is important to you? And how do you imagine it's going to make your life better? Really, really think about that. is the outcome of your resolution? Is it going to be enough to motivate you to do the things that you need to do?|||那就是诚实。对自己诚实，弄清楚你到底想要什么，你为什么想实现它以及它有多大实现的可能性。所以在你设定2023年的决心之前，非常重要的一点是问自己一些核心问题，并在回答时对自我保持诚实。为什么这个目标对你很重要？你想象它将如何让你的生活变得更好？认认真真、仔仔细细地想想这个问题。是你的决心的结果吗？它是否足以激励你去做你需要做的事情？
And is that final end goal, something that is achievable? Honestly, it's also important to reflect on the times when you've tried in the past to achieve this thing or to pursue this change and what went wrong. You know, maybe last year you wanted to wake up at 7 a.m. every day, but you didn't think about the fact that you work a night to be. or that a lot of your socializing happens in the evening. So think about why you failed. Think about what it was about your environment, about your surroundings that made it difficult to accomplish this goal. We often, you know, set lofty goals for the future without seriously and honestly
And is that final end goal, something that is achievable? Honestly, it's also important to reflect on the times when you've tried in the past to achieve this thing or to pursue this change and what went wrong. You know, maybe last year you wanted to wake up at 7 a.m. every day, but you didn't think about the fact that you work a night to be. or that a lot of your socializing happens in the evening. So think about why you failed. Think about what it was about your environment, about your surroundings that made it difficult to accomplish this goal. We often, you know, set lofty goals for the future without seriously and honestly|||而最终的终极目标，是一个可以实现的目标吗？老实说，反思过去你曾试图实现这一目标或追求这种改变却遭遇失败的经历，这也同样重要。你知道，也许去年你想每天早上7点起床，但你没有考虑到你上夜班的事实。或者你的很多社交活动都是在晚上进行的。所以想想你为什么会失败。想想你的环境、你的周围有什么因素导致你难以完成这个目标。我们经常（你知道的）为未来设定崇高的目标，却没有认真且诚实地
assessing why we've probably struggled in the past and without examining where we are resistant to change that cycle of that, you know, that cycle of excitement and resolve. and then failure continues to repeat. It's also really important to be honest about what else is going to have to change in your life to meet your goal and to meet your resolution. We often think about our New Year's resolutions as a pretty isolated desire or an isolated dream without recognizing the lifestyle change that they are going to require. The one I always think of is the New Year's resolution to quit drinking,
assessing why we've probably struggled in the past and without examining where we are resistant to change that cycle of that, you know, that cycle of excitement and resolve. and then failure continues to repeat. It's also really important to be honest about what else is going to have to change in your life to meet your goal and to meet your resolution. We often think about our New Year's resolutions as a pretty isolated desire or an isolated dream without recognizing the lifestyle change that they are going to require. The one I always think of is the New Year's resolution to quit drinking,|||评估我们过去可能一直在挣扎的原因，也没有审视我们在哪里抗拒改变，那种循环——你知道的，那种兴奋和下定决心的循环，然后失败不断重复。坦诚面对为了实现你的目标和决心，你的生活还需要发生哪些改变，这也非常重要。我们经常把我们的新年决心看作是一个相当孤立的愿望或一个孤立的梦想，却没有意识到它们将需要的生活方式的改变。我总是想起的一个例子就是戒酒的新年决心，
and that's one of mine for this year. quitting, you know, to quit drinking, quitting alcohol, it sounds simple enough, right? You know, you just say no. You just don't drink. And when you think about it on an individual basis, when you're home by yourself, it sounds pretty achievable, right? Like, it sounds fairly simple. But then you have to think about it in terms of the other contexts in our lives, in which
and that's one of my for this year. quitting, you know, to quit drinking, quitting alcohol, it sounds simple enough, right? You know, you just say no. You just don't drink. And when you think about it on an individual basis, when you're home by yourself, it sounds pretty achievable, right? Like, it sounds fairly simple. But then you have to think about it in terms of the other contexts in our lives, in which|||这也是我今年的目标之一。戒酒，你知道的，戒掉喝酒，戒掉酒精，听起来很简单，对吧？你知道，你只要说不就行了。你只要不喝就行了。当你以个人的角度去考虑它时，当你独自在家时，听起来相当可以实现，对吧？就像，听起来挺简单的。但随后你必须从我们生活的其他背景来考虑它，在这些背景中
alcohol is present, and how much it tends to dominate social occasions. and celebrations. Are you going to be okay with not drinking during these times or maybe missing out because of this choice? And are you going to be able to make the changes to your overall lifestyle to enact this goal? By asking ourselves these questions and also answering them honestly, we're actually setting ourselves up for success because we can alter our resolutions and be more realistic from the get-go and therefore more likely to succeed. There are of course some other reasons why we typically fail our New Year's resolutions just to list off a couple.
酒精无处不在，并且往往在社交场合和庆祝活动中占据主导地位。在这些时候不喝酒，或者可能因为这个选择而错失乐趣，你觉得可以接受吗？你是否能够对整体生活方式做出改变以实现这个目标？通过问自己这些问题并诚实地回答，我们实际上是在为成功做好准备，因为我们可以从一开始就修改决心，使其更切合实际，从而更有可能成功。当然，我们通常无法实现新年愿望还有其他一些原因，这里仅列举几个。
Sometimes we just lack accountability. You know, it's very easy to fail if the only person you're going to disappoint is yourself. Sometimes our goal doesn't allow for small wins. So we give up because we don't see any progress. maybe it is a lack of planning or the stakes are just too low and sometimes it's just about self-doubt and not believing that we're able to do them we're not able to achieve what we set our minds to with all of that in mind i really want to turn to our final point for this episode and perhaps the most significant how can we actually be successful with all of this information and
有时我们只是缺乏责任感。你知道的，如果唯一会让你失望的人只有你自己，那么失败是非常容易的。有时我们的目标不允许有小的胜利，所以我们因为看不到任何进展而放弃。也许是缺乏规划，或者赌注太低，有时甚至只是自我怀疑，不相信自己能够做到，不相信我们能够实现自己内心的想法。考虑到所有这些，我真的想转向我们这一集的最后一点，也许也是最重要的一点：带着所有这些信息和知识，我们究竟该如何取得成功？
knowledge in mind, what can we learn from our failures so that we can see through our resolutions. We can make the change that we want to in our lives. Luckily for us, there is quite a lot of research on this. So I've gathered a few tips for us to all share and to hopefully learn from. Firstly, start small. Creating smaller goals that are practical and don't restrict you to. much is going to be so much more achievable because those goals and the actions required to meet them are not going to disrupt your life as much. Think about all of those automatic behaviors that
我们可以从失败中学到什么，以便实现我们的决心？我们可以做出生活中想要的改变。对我们幸运的是，关于这方面的研究相当多。所以我收集了一些建议，供大家分享，并希望从中吸取教训。首先，从微小处着手。制定切实可行且不会对你造成太大限制的更小目标，会更容易实现，因为这些目标以及实现它们所需的行动不会对你的生活造成太大干扰。想想所有那些我们之前讨论过的自动行为。
we were talking about before. Undermining them and rewriting them takes a lot of effort. But if we start out small, you know, maybe by initially trying to exercise just for five minutes out of the day of just trying to replace certain foods that are making us feel unwell. It's a lot easier to integrate into our lives rather than trying to completely shift our lifestyle overnight. These resolutions are also be easier for you to stick to because you're not going to feel like you're missing out and you'll still be able to move closer to your big goal. Sometimes I think we get so excited and we are so impatient that we just rush to the finish line. and what ends up happening is that it's a not very sustainable and b we just end up failing because
破坏并重写它们需要付出很大的努力。但如果我们从小处着手，比方说最初尝试一天只锻炼五分钟，或者试着替换掉那些让我们感觉不适的特定食物，这就更容易融入我们的生活，而不是试图在一夜之间彻底改变我们的生活方式。这些决心也会更容易让你坚持下去，因为你不会觉得自己错过了什么，而且你仍然能够朝着你的宏大目标迈进。有时我认为我们太兴奋、太急躁，以至于直接冲向终点线，结果就是：a) 不太具有可持续性，b) 我们最终还是会失败，因为
any kind of massive life change is going to take so much energy similar to this is ensuring that your goals are clearly defined i think often we set these very big sweeping goals and we make these big statements like i want to be healthier or i want to make new friends or i want to be more successful. But unfortunately, those goals, as amazing as they sound, they're not very clear, and it's hard to hold yourself accountable if you don't really have a vision or an idea of success in mind. So making sure that you know exactly what it is you're working for, you create a resolution so that you can actionably see when you're getting closer to the end outcome is going to really help you. And as a sense,
任何形式的大规模生活改变都需要耗费大量的精力。与此类似的是确保你的目标有明确的定义。我认为通常我们会设定非常宏大、笼统的目标，并发表一些宏大的声明，比如我想变得更健康，我想结交新朋友，或者我想变得更成功。但不幸的是，这些目标虽然听起来很棒，但并不是很清晰，如果你没有一个真正的愿景或对成功的构想，就很难让自己负起责任。因此，确保你清楚地知道自己在为什么努力，制定一个决心，以便你能切实体会到自己何时正在接近最终结果，这将会对你大有帮助。在此意义上，
similar vein to both of those things, I think also limiting yourself to a few resolutions, maybe just one, is also going to be really, really helpful and really enable your success. It's really tempting to do these big to-do lists and to have all these really insane expectations for what we're capable of doing. Maybe you're someone who can handle that amount of pressure and that many things on your mind, but most of us can't really focus on a huge list at once. It's better to break it down into maybe just one or two, one or two goals that we really want to achieve. And that way, we're not as easily overwhelmed and as frustrated. And we can integrate those goals into our life a bit better. If we've decided, you know,
与这两点类似，我认为将自己限制在少数几个决心（也许只有一个）范围内，也将是非常非常有帮助的，并且真正能够促成你的成功。列出庞大的待办事项清单，对我们能够做到的事情抱有所有这些极其疯狂的期望，这真的很有诱惑力。也许你是那种能够应付那种压力和脑海中那么多事情的人，但我们大多数人无法同时专注于一个巨大的清单。最好把它精简到也许只有一个或两个，一个或两个我们真正想要实现的目标。这样一来，我们就不会那么容易感到压抑和沮丧，并且我们可以更好地将这些目标融入我们的生活。如果我们已经决定，
I want to exercise more and then I want to eat better and then I want to be more sustainable and I want to spend money better, that is a lot. That is a lot. So maybe try and find a goal that links all of them, like walking to work. That is sustainable, it's a great exercise, and it saves you money because you don't have to pay for petrol or pay for transport. Another few tips that I kind of gathered was to be realistic. I think we've talked about that already. Find community, and with that accountability. If your goal is shared, you're able to relate to others who are going through similar things or facing similar setbacks. And also, you feel accountable and you're excited to pursue the goal because you have community surrounding it. Find a way to track your progress
我想多锻炼，然后我想吃得更好，然后我想更具可持续性，我还想更好地花钱，这可太多了。这实在是太多了。所以也许试着找一个能将所有这些联系起来的目标，比如步行上班。这具有可持续性，是一项很棒的锻炼，而且可以省钱，因为你不必支付汽油费或交通费。我收集的另外几个建议是保持现实。我想我们已经讨论过这一点了。寻找社群，并借此建立责任感。如果你的目标是共享的，你就能够与那些经历类似事情或面临类似挫折的人产生共鸣。而且，你也会感到有责任感，并且因为有社群环绕而对追求目标感到兴奋。寻找追踪进度的方法
and see the small wins. When we set a big goal and it's in the future and it's going to take a lot for us to get there, we can become disheartened quite easily because we don't see any output from our efforts. So find a way to track your progress or to give yourself some small wins to motivate you along the way. One way that I do this is I create kind of like a visual vision board or a resource to think about what I want to achieve and why. And it helps me keep focused and really visualize the outcome that I want and why I want it. It's been so helpful. I do this at the start of most years where I create like a bit of a collage about where I see my year going. It's firstly a really great way to reflect and see what it is that I've realized about that, but it also makes it
并看到微小的胜利。当我们设定一个宏大的、在未来的目标，且需要付出很大努力才能到达时，我们很容易变得沮丧，因为我们看不到付出带来的任何产出。所以，寻找一种追踪进度或给自己一些小胜利的方法，以便在沿途激励你。我做到这一点的一种方法是创建一种类似于视觉愿景板或资源的工具，来思考我想实现什么以及为什么。它有助于我保持专注，并真正将我想要的成果以及我为什么想要它视觉化。这真的太有帮助了。我在大多数年份开始时都会这样做，创建一个关于我看到自己这一年走向何方的拼贴画。这首先是一个反思和审视我对此有何认识的绝佳方式，但它也让我
really clear to me about what it is I'm working towards and I don't lose sight in all the chaos of our day-to-day lives. Finally, it's so important to be mindful, take responsibility for your actions and to stay committed, but also not get too wrapped up in one goal, right? You want your life to be enjoyable. And often if you put all your eggs in one basket, if you're too dedicated, if you go about it really intensely, you're not going to be successful because you're just going to be exhausted and you're going to lose motivation really, really fast.
非常清楚地了解我正在为什么努力，并且在日常生活的种种混乱中，我不会迷失方向。最后，保持正念是如此重要，要对自己的行动负责并保持坚定，但也不要太过于陷入某一个目标中，对吧？你希望你的生活充满乐趣。通常如果你把所有的鸡蛋放在一个篮子里，如果你过于投入，如果你以非常强烈的方式去处理它，你将不会成功，因为你最终会筋疲力尽，并且会非常非常快地失去动力。
So start with a picture of your future self in mind, make that image big and bright. Imagine what it feels like. imagine how you feel and hold that really deeply. Hold onto it as a daily reminder for what you are working for and why you're working towards that. Change your phone background or something about your environment that reminds you of your goal every day.
所以，从脑海中构想出未来自己的画面开始，让这个形象变得宏大而明亮。想象一下那种感觉，想象你的感受，并牢牢地把它记在心里。把它作为每日的提醒，提醒你正在为什么努力以及你为什么要朝着这个目标努力。更换你的手机壁纸或改变你环境中的某些东西，每天都能提醒你记住你的目标。
I saw this really interesting quote. I think it's a great thing to share to end up to, you know, to wrap up this episode. Winners and losers have the same goals. It's all about who is most. consistent. You're allowed to have setbacks. You're allowed to have failures. But if you keep working at it day by day, you just aim to be 1% better every day. It's going to be achievable. And I wish you the best of luck. I hope that you're successful. How amazing to be setting New Year's resolutions. I am so excited for the new year and all that's going to come with it. It's going to
我看到了这句非常有趣的名言。我认为把它分享出来作为这一集的总结非常棒。赢家和输家拥有相同的目标。关键在于谁最具连贯性。你被允许遭遇挫折，你被允许经历失败。但如果你日复一日地坚持下去，只是目标每天比前一天好1%的话，这就一定能够实现。我祝你一切顺利。我希望你能成功。设立新年愿望是多么了不起的一件事啊。我为新年以及随之而来的一切感到无比兴奋。这将是
be a big year for the podcast. And I cannot thank you enough for supporting me throughout 2022. So thank you to all the new listeners, to everyone who shared, to everyone who's messaged me and followed me, I am so grateful and I cannot wait to push this even further and do so many amazing things in the new year. If you enjoyed this episode, if you think that other people would enjoy it as well, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you get your podcasts. It really helps the show to grow and to reach new people. so if you feel called to do so, it makes a huge difference. And yeah, I would love, I'd be very grateful if you would do that.
播客意义重大的一年。我非常感谢大家在2022年对我的支持。所以感谢所有新听众，感谢每一个分享过的人，感谢每一个给我发信息和关注我的人，我对此感激不尽，我迫不及待地想把这一切推向更高的高度，并在新的一年里做许多了不起的事情。如果你喜欢这一集，如果你认为其他人也会喜欢它，请随时在苹果播客、Spotify或你获取播客的任何地方留下五星好评。这真的对节目的成长和接触新受众有很大帮助，所以如果你觉得有必要这样做，它会产生巨大的影响。是的，如果你能这么做，我会非常感激。
And if you're interested in seeing more of my content, please follow our Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. Often I let listeners of the show decide the episodes that I publish for the week. So if that is something you are interested in, please give us a follow and participate in the community that way. Thank you again for listening. good luck if you've set a new year's resolution. I'm sure you're going to do amazing and I will see you next week for a new episode. Hey, what's good y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your
如果你有兴趣看到我的更多内容，请关注我们的Instagram账号：That Psychology Podcast。通常我会让节目的听众来决定我本周发布的剧集。所以如果这是你感兴趣的事情，请给我们一个关注，并通过这种方式参与到社群中来。再次感谢大家的收听。如果你设定了新年愿望，祝你好运。我确信你会做得非常棒，我们下周的新节目再见。嘿，大家好！你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Keer Games）主持的《艰难学习》（Learn the Hardway）。这个空间关注的是黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都绝对不安全进行的诚实对话，但你们是在与一位知晓其事的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套或一身铠甲？这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这个护甲，并不意味着你就需要它。在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学习》。2%。这是当电梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。
favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the case. That does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我剖析了我们在奇怪的现代世界中培养坚韧精神、体能和韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终将成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的。收听《2%》。即数字“2%”，请在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。
I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他将得到他应得的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。请在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客、
I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to The Girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts,
或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回看往事》（The Look Back at It Podcast）节目中。从1979年开始，对我和说那是个重大时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一集，我们挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，
or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at It Podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down,
并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。同我们的朋友、喜剧同仁和最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说没有比这更重要的一年了。收听《回看往事》，请在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个iHeart播客。
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
有人类保证。本集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。
Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请勿在json块之外包含任何额外的文本。